you don't have an option to be scrappy
or innovative you have to otherwise you
don't have a chance to be successful
my name is ron mcnermell i'm the ceo of
acuco i'm 29 years old
so at accuco we work with third-party
e-commerce sellers most of these guys
are mom-and-pop shops and what we do is
we go out and acquire their brands allow
them to participate in the growth of
their brand alongside us
and let them have an opportunity to exit
i'm a first generation
sikh american i immigrated with my
family from india at the age of seven
what was really interesting is that my
parents didn't want to take any money
from their parents they wanted to come
here and truly you know build their own
future and i wanted to follow in their
footsteps and do the same so at the age
of 14 i started my first online company
i was able to actually generate enough
money to pay for my college tuition as
well as my apartment in college as well
my first job out of college was actually
at amazon started out as a business
analyst but what was really interesting
was what i was really able to achieve
there my boss told me why don't you go
out and start a brand on amazon see how
well that does learn you know the
difficult points that sellers have with
e-commerce and the tools that we can
help build to empower sellers to be
successful on our platform i did so over
the next six months after which i
actually left amazon to pursue selling
on amazon full-time because that brand
that i'd started we sold over seven
million dollars in our first year so
really have been you know in this space
for seven years have been living and
breathing amazon and rather than going
out and building our brands from the
ground up or consulting for some of the
largest sellers why not take all that
knowledge and expertise and then go out
and buy
some of the best brands that exist and
help grow those to the next level
you have to work hard for everything and
earn it yourself whether that's building
something from the ground up or working
with and getting the most talented
people that you can to work with you to
build something things aren't going to
get handed down to you you have to be
the one that does it and just you know
focusing on that has allowed me to
succeed
[Music]